عمرو حلبي متواجد في كهرمان مراش عمرو هل
يبدو ان هناك ثبات في تصويت المناطق التي
شهدت زلزاله مدمرا قبل اشهر
جلال فقط قبل ان يتوسع بالاجابه عن هذا
السؤال تعني فقط انقل لك المشهد من حيث
نحن من وسط كهرمان مرش المدينه نستطيع ان
نقول بان معظم انصار الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان قد خرجوا الى الشوارع احتفالا
دعني اقول لك حتى الساعه ربما احتفالا
بتصويت مدينتهم بنسبه حتى الان
70.8 في المئه
للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بعد ان
فتحت وبعد ان فرزت نحو 77 بالمئه من
صناديق الاقتراع لكن ان نقول فرحا بفوز
الرئيس التركي لكن لا يزال هذا مبكرا لكن
على الذين التقيناهم فان هذا ما يؤمنون به
وما يعتقدونه وتسمعون ربما الان ايضا
الاصوات اطلاق للنار في الهواء اطلاق
اعجره ناريه احتفاليه من قبل هؤلاء
احتفالات حاشده الشوارع الرئيسيه في
المدينه خصوصا وسط المدينه مغلقه تماما في
الساحات تجمع انصار الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان وهم يحتفلون بما بما اسماه
ايمانهم بفوز الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان وبتصويت مدينتهم حتى الساعه وحتى
الان وفق نتائج الاوليه كذلك للرئيس
التركي والتحالف الجمهور الحاكم لكن اذا
ما اتجهنا الان الى نتائج الرسميه الاوليه
بكل تاكيد او عفوا اذا ما اتجهنا الى
النتائج الاوليه جلال دعني اقول بان
اثنتين من اصل احدى عشره ولايه تركيه
صوتتا لصالح رئيس تحالف للشعب المعارض
كمان وهما اضن وديار بكر اضنه حتى الان ما
تزال طبعا في نتائج الاستطاعات في النتائج
الفرز الاصوات الاوليه اضنا بنسبه 45.7 في
المئه مقابل
48.8 بالمئه لصالح كمالك اما ديار بكر فهي
معروفه بانها تصوت للمعارضه بالاصل باقي
والمتضرره من الزلزال حتى الان قد اعطت
صوتها لصالح تحالف الجمهور الحاكم ولصالح
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بالترتيب
بالدرجه الرئيسيه الاولى من حيث اعداد
الناخبين واكبر عدد لان الناخبين في هذه
الولايات اضنه كما قلت هي صوتت حتى الساعه
بنسبه 60 فاصله بنسبه نحو 60 في المئه بعد
فرز الاصوات لصالح كمالك يليها بعد ذلك
غازي عنتاب صوتت لصالح الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان ثم هاتاي هاتاي التي هي جلال
هي محسوبه على المعارضه لكنها حتى الان
تظهر نتائج
الاوليه فيها بان الاصوات متجهه لصالح
الرئيس التركي رجب اردوغان بنسبه 51.8 في
المئه بعد فرز نحو 59,3 من الاصوات اذا
بشكل عام معظم الولايات حتى الساعه لصالح
الرئيس التركي مقابل اثنتين صوتتان لصالح
كماله